even though I could not see or hear
anything I could sense the world losing
patience with me but still I needed to
communicate so did you guys won a
quarter Duty some more time I tried
everything I imagined Helen must have
tried classic charades style clue
guttural moaning surely one of these
tools commonly used by the disabled
would do the trick
sounds like but on a day when I wanted
to be taken to see my ex-wife I was
instead robbed of my shoes on a day when
I wanted a light snack I was instead
given a pen on a day when I wanted to
play catch with my son Erik like I used
to I was instead brought to a drug party
and finally on a day when I wanted to be
taken for a stroll outside
I was troublingly brought to court where
I was facing trial for murder
my caretakers had failed me
spectacularly this was the worst
possible time to be deaf dumb and fly
and what is your relationship with your
ex-husband I was unable to discuss
anything with my lawyer he's my
ex-husband who made the questionable
decision to call my ex-wife as a
character witness during the time of
your marriage did he bring you flowers
or pay your compliments yes he did he
did stuff like that yes oh he sounds
like a really nice guy doesn't he no
further questions your honor
while everyone tried to ignore the
presence of a grunting visitor from the
19th century Suzanne was as if she
thought I would commit murder for the
show no I don't he is overly committed
to his work but he's not so committed
that he would actually kill somebody
and then unbeknownst to me my lawyer
made an even more perplexing decision
the defense would like to call Forrest
MacNeil this way ma'am there you go
we had always planned before igneel to
testify down down down my attorney saw
no reason to change course despite the
fact that Forrest MacNeil was now Helen
Keller thank you for coming to testify
today mr. MacNeil uh there was much for
Forrest MacNeil could have said in his
own defense is it true that that guy ray
attacked you first indeed it was true
ray the man who was killed was a violent
sociopath Oh Oh God can I get out of
here a man who would surely have been
killed by somebody someday you did this
in self-defense
is that true Thorin say yes just say yes
the answer was yes I had no doubt ray
was beating me to death you did this in
self-defense is that true all you have
to do is say yes but yes but Helen could
not answer even if she had known she was
testifying to save my life okay for me
if only my attorney had tried harder to
remove my helmet or had not called me to
the stand at all now and you'd see mile
hatin conscience in his chair I think we
got to go back to the seat being in
constant need of assistance made it
clear that in life be careful all right
it's good enough for me
we are surrounded by people who do not
fully apply themselves to their duty as
a result I was not able to exonerate
myself and review once again left my
fate in the hands of fate living as
Helen Keller was an isolating experience
that required trust perseverance and a
high tolerance for minor abrasions she
was a remarkable woman
and for a little while so was I I give
being Helen Keller five jobs
you